ASH AHLUWALIA: Hello, and
welcome to Storage 202,
Getting Beyond Data Gravity--
Moving Your Data to Cloud.
I am one of your
co-hosts, Ash Ahluwalia.
I'm a product manager for
the Google Cloud platform
and I work on
transfer products that
help you move your
data over the network.
ABHISHEK LAL: Thanks, Ash.
Hi, folks.
I'm Abhishek Lal,
a product manager
with Google Cloud Platform.
I'm excited to present this
session today and discuss
moving your data to the cloud.
We will start by discussing
data transfer use cases
and challenges, then move to
some exciting announcements
that we have to share.
We will also do a deep dive
into all the new capabilities.
And finally, conclude with
Q&A at the end of the session.
ASH AHLUWALIA: So
to start, let's
talk a little bit about why we
built this suite of transfer
products.
And the principal
motivation is that being
able to move your data is
an important prerequisite
to getting value out
of your Google Cloud
investment across a
variety of use cases,
whether you're trying to
lower your costs by archiving
or offloading your
storage to the cloud,
or in situations
where you're trying
to get more value from your
data by running analytical
or machine learning pipelines.
It also applies in
situations where
you're lifting and
shifting the workload
to cloud as part of a larger
transformation initiative.
And in some instances,
it's important to be
able to move your data
to share information
between organizations
within your company
and with external
partners and customers.
ABHISHEK LAL: When moving
your data into the cloud,
customers may face
several challenges.
Scaling your
processes and scripts
to terabytes and even
petabytes is laborious.
Utilizing all of
your resources--
from source IOPS,
network bandwidth,
and then optimizing
tools and API calls--
requires a lot of tuning.
Validating data integrity across
formats and transfer errors
can be tricky.
And finally, all
the time that you
spend in building this knowledge
and completing the operations
could be better
spent on something
that has longer-term
sustained business value.
Hence, at Google Cloud, we
have several transfer services
to address these challenges.
Next, Ash will provide an
overview of what we offer.
ASH AHLUWALIA: Let's talk a
bit about the transfer product
offerings that we have today.
And we'll start with the
storage transfer service, which
is a managed service for
large-scale batch data
transfers from one
GCP region to another
or from other clouds like AWS
S3 into Google Cloud Storage.
The second product offering,
the storage transfer service
for on premises data,
helps you move data
from on premises file systems
into Google Cloud Storage.
That is also a managed service
for large-scale batch data
transfers.
In some instances, you
need to move your data
from your private
data center to cloud,
and it's just a
small bit of data.
And for that, we offer the
gsutil command-line utility.
This is a utility you can
invoke inside of a script
or from a shell as part
of your daily workflow.
Now, all of the products
that I've talked about so far
move data over the network.
In some instances,
you have too much data
to move over the network--
it would just take too long,
or you may have no network
connectivity at all.
In those instances,
we can ship you
a physical product called
the Transfer Appliance, which
you can load with data and
then ship back to Google
for upload to the cloud.
So let's now talk a little
bit about the new product
announcements and updates that
we've made to these services.
We'll start with the Storage
Transfer Service, which
moves data between clouds.
We're really excited
today to announce
that we're launching a public
global beta for supporting
Azure blob storage.
This will enable you to move
data from Azure blob storage
to Google Cloud Storage
with all of the features
that we offer for S3 to Google
Cloud Storage transfers today.
In addition, we're
announcing a public beta
for VPC Service Controls.
This will enable
you to move data
from outside of Google Cloud
into a Google Cloud Storage
bucket that is inside
of a security perimeter.
In addition, it will enable
you to move data between two
security perimeters.
If the source bucket
is in one parameter
and the destination
bucket is in another,
it will enable you to
move data between the two.
Finally, we've launched
a number of improvements
for programmatic
usage of the service,
starting with the
customer provided job-IDs.
This will enable you to set
the transfer ID for transfers
you're executing so you don't
have to maintain mappings
to other ID spaces.
For instance, if you're
running pipelines
that do a lot of
data transfers, you
can just use your pipeline
run ID as your job ID,
and that will make
troubleshooting and tracking
a whole lot easier.
We're also enabling the
ability to choose objects
from the source based on
their last modified time.
So you can also, for instance,
move all objects that
were last modified in January.
And finally, we're
announcing the availability
of PubSub notifications.
When a transfer completes,
we will publish a message
to a PubSub topic that you
have configured in advance.
And you can then
use that message
to trigger downstream actions.
For instance, if you
want to now start
processing the data
that's been transferred,
you can do so programmatically
with that PubSub notification.
Now, let's talk about the
storage transfer service
for on premises data.
This was announced as entering
public beta late last year
in Cloud Next London,
and we're really
excited to announce today
that we are launching it
into public GA.
In addition, we
have added support
for VPC Service
Controls in beta.
This will allow you to move
data from your on premises
file system into Google Cloud
Storage buckets that are inside
of a security perimeter.
In addition, this
will make the service
compatible with scenarios where
security perimeter extends
beyond cloud and includes
your on premises [? fiber ?]
resources.
Now, let me pass
it on to Abhishek
to talk about updates
for Transfer Appliance.
ABHISHEK LAL: Thank you, Ash.
I'm excited to announce a
new [? SKU ?] of the Transfer
Appliance.
Currently, we have TA100
and TA480 as the two models
available.
In coming months, we
will roll out the TA300.
Next, let's understand
each of these new features
and capabilities in detail.
ASH AHLUWALIA: So let's start
by doing a quick walkthrough--
virtual demo, if you will--
of the storage transfer service.
Moving data from
Azure blob storage
to a Google Cloud
Storage bucket.
Now, before we do that, let's
just talk a little bit more
about what this service
is designed to do.
So firstly, it's
designed to be fast.
It uses Google
infrastructure underneath.
So you're using, for instance,
Google's provision network
pipes from Google data centers
to AWS and Azure data centers.
In addition, it's designed to
scale to petabytes of data.
And then finally,
we will allocate
a number of workers
behind the scenes
to parallelize
your data transfer.
And you don't have to
deal with any of that.
That's all happening
seamlessly behind the scenes
without any management
or intervention from you.
Secondly, it's
designed to be easy.
The interface is very simple.
You choose your source
bucket and credentials,
your destination bucket and
schedule, and then hit Go.
And it starts moving your data.
And we will talk through
a more detailed example
in just a little bit.
It also supports moving data
from Azure blob storage, S3,
and you can also give
it a list of HTTP URLs.
So any data you can
reach with the browser,
you can move with this product.
And finally, it's
compatible with
all GCP-supported languages.
So it should be
easy to integrate
within your current
architecture.
And finally, this service
is designed to be secure.
All connections are encrypted
with TLS encryption.
It supports IAM,
so you can control
which users can transfer data,
which users can edit transfers.
And then also supports
data integrity
by doing checksums of objects
at the source and destination
to make sure that no bytes
have been corrupted in flight.
And finally, as
we just announced,
it supports VPC-Service
Controls, now in beta.
So let's walk through a more
detailed example and demo.
So if you're going to start
to move data from Azure blob
Storage to GCS, there's
some initial setup
you need to do for the product.
As with many Google
Cloud Platform products,
you need to give
yourself-- your client--
application access to the
Storage Transfer Service API.
And in addition, you need
to give the Storage Transfer
Service service account, which
moves data on your behalf,
access to your source
and destination.
Now, once you do that, let's
just talk through how does
a transfer actually
work with the service.
There are two key
concepts to understand.
The first is the job.
The job essentially
encapsulates the configuration
for what you want to
do in the transfer--
the source, destination,
credentials, schedules,
transfer options, and
that sort of thing.
And then the second concept
that's important to understand
is the operation.
The operation captures a
specific instance or execution
of a transfer.
So for instance, you
may configure a job
to run every day at noon.
And you will have an operation
for Tuesday's run at noon,
which will tell you specifically
what happened on that transfer,
with counters and errors
and that sort of thing.
So submitting a
job is essentially
just a two-step process.
You submit a config.
The config will tell
you when this transfer
should be scheduled to run.
And then, the service on its
own when the schedule fires
will create a transfer operation
and execute the transfer
as you configured it.
So let's take a look at that
in a little bit more detail.
Here's an example
we have of how you
might use our REST interface
to submit a new transfer job.
Now, let's just zoom
into pieces of this
so we can understand
what information you're
sending along.
We'll start with
information about the source
and destination.
So as you can see here, you
would supply information
about your Azure blob
storage account, container,
and your credentials so we
can access your source data.
In addition, you would
supply information
about the destination GCS bucket
where you want your data to go.
Another part of the
proto is schedules.
Schedules are comprised
of three parts.
First, when does
this schedule start?
When does it end?
And at what time do we execute?
All storage transfer
service jobs run daily.
So in this example,
hours is equal to 1
and minutes is equal
to 1, which means
this job will run at 1:01 AM.
And then finally,
you can also submit
a number of transfer
options, which
will help you control whether
you're allowed to overwrite
data for objects that already
exist at the destination,
or if you want, for
instance, to delete data
after it's been copied.
So more of a move
operation instead
of creating a second copy.
And then you can also
submit information
about what source objects
you want us to select.
For instance, you
can choose objects
based on the last
modified time, or you
can use include and
execute prefixes
to choose objects
based on their name.
So for example, you could choose
an include prefix of foo slash,
and that would mean that we put
all objects whose prefix starts
with foo slash.
So after you submit a job,
you're going to get a response.
And as you can see from this
pretty big response here,
most of that response
is the config
that you provided
played back to you.
But there's some
of that response
that I think is important
to highlight, so let's
zoom in on that.
Now, if we take a
look at that, there
are some standard
metadata you might expect.
We can tell you when
the job configuration
resource was created, but we
also include the job name.
This is a unique identifier
at the project level
that you can use to make
subsequent calls if you want
to, for instance, figure
out whether the job is still
running, what
operations have been
executed as part of the job.
So if, for instance, you
want to monitor a transfer,
let's just look at that example
in a little bit more detail.
This is, again, showing you
the request that you're making
and the full response.
Now, let's just zoom
into pieces of it
so we can understand
it a bit better.
So first, starting
with the request.
As I mentioned before, you
submit the project ID and then
this unique job name, which
will help us identify the job
resource and respond.
And the response will contain
the list of operations
that have been executed
or are executing as part
of this job configuration.
Now, if you look at
aspects of the response,
it's an array of operations.
And each operation will contain
some important information.
It will contain when
this execution began,
when it completed, and what
status it competed with--
was it a success or a failure.
It will also include
error information
that you might use for
detailed troubleshooting.
And it will also
include some counters
that will help you understand
how much data actually made it
in both byte and in count units.
So let's look through those
counters in a little bit
more detail.
So in both byte and
count units, we're
showing you essentially every
aspect of what the service did.
How many objects did we find?
How many objects did
we take action on,
whether we were copying
them or deleting them
at the source or destination?
And then finally, how
many objects or bytes
did we fail to act on?
So you can use this for some of
your more detailed monitoring.
So that was an example
of how we moved data
from Azure blob storage
to Google Cloud storage.
Now let's talk about the
storage transfer service
for on premises
data, which helps
you move data from private
data centers to Google Cloud.
So an overview of this service.
It is designed,
again, to be fast.
This service requires you to
install a piece of software
which we call the agent to help
us push data to Google Cloud.
And we worked a lot to
make that process seamless.
All you need to do is cut
and paste a few commands,
and your agent is
installed and ready to go.
It's also designed to
scale to petabytes of data
and multiple tens of
gigabits per second,
so it is very appropriate to
use for large data transfers.
And then finally, this service
is designed to be scalable.
So if you want the service to
run faster, all you need to do
is bring up more agents
and we will push more data
in parallel.
And you should be able
to get better speeds.
Secondly, it's
designed to be easy.
We try to make the
management and operation
of this product as simple
and easy as possible for you.
So for instance, the
agents offer auto updates.
You don't have to
worry about that.
It works just like Chrome
auto updates do today.
It also works on all connection
types that Google supports.
So whether you're using
the public internet,
direct interconnect, or
partner interconnect,
as long as you can
connect to the cloud,
this product should be
able to move data for you.
And finally, it's
designed to be secure.
It uses TLS encryption to
protect your data while it's
in flight, and also
computes checksums
at the source and
destination to make sure
that no bytes have been
corrupted while the transfer is
occurring.
And finally, as we
mentioned before,
it also now supports in public
beta security perimeters.
So let's talk a little
bit more about what
the journey looks
like when you're
trying to use this product.
So as I mentioned before,
the first step to set it up
is to download and install
our agent software.
This software sits inside
of a Docker container image,
so that container actually
contains more than just
the binary for the agent.
It also contains this
auto-updating component
that we talked about earlier,
and the process monitor.
So if the agent process
dies within the container,
we can bounce it back up without
you having to worry about it
or include that in
your operations.
And the other thing
I'll just mention
is because this is inside
of a Docker container,
we encourage you to use that
with whatever orchestration
mechanism you have.
For instance, if you use
Kubernetes to run many agents,
that'll help us
parallelize your transfer
and get you faster speeds.
Once you've done
this one-time setup,
then running a transfer is as
simple as going into the Google
Cloud console--
the GUI for the Google
Cloud platform--
and submitting a source
directory in the destination
bucket.
And once you do that,
the agents will all
start working in parallel
to move your data across.
And you can monitor what's
happening with your transfer
right there in the GUI.
You can see what errors
have been recorded
and all the counters that
we talked about earlier.
In addition, one thing
I'd like to highlight
is that this agent
fabric is fault-tolerant.
So if, let's say, you're running
10 agents and five of them
go down, the transfer
will still keep running.
And it might run a little bit
slower because fewer agents are
running, but the transfer
will still make progress.
If all of the agents go
down, that's OK, too.
The transfer won't
make progress,
because there are no agents
available to push data.
But as soon as
agents come back up,
all of your pending
transfers will pick up
where they left off.
So you don't have to implement
any sort of special recovery
or retry logic.
This service has all
of that built in.
With that, let me pass
it over to Abhishek
to talk a little bit more about
the new Transfer Appliance
product that we announced today.
ABHISHEK LAL: Thank
you so much, Ash.
I'm excited to introduce
the Google Transfer
Appliance, TA300.
We are always
listening to our users
to understand their
evolving needs.
And this new appliance
addresses several
of the features and
requirements you have asked for.
Next, let me highlight
these asks from customers.
When migrating
workloads, customers
want to minimize the
downtime and thus
reduce impact to their users.
Fast transfers reduce
the disruptions
to rhythms of business
when moving applications
to the cloud.
Moving large data
volumes can sometimes
be disruptive to already
stretched network bandwidth.
And the cost
considerations could
make it unattractive to go
and procure new circuits.
Finally, there are remote
and mobile situations,
like ships, when you need
to collect data locally
and in a secure and
efficient manner.
Once you dock at
the port, you want
to then move this data
quickly to the cloud.
Learnings from these
users have helped
to guide the design of the
next generation of transfer
appliances.
The new Transfer
Appliance, TA300,
delivers a simple,
secure, and performant way
to move your data into
Google Cloud platform.
This is targeted
at customers who
are unable to move data online
due to limited bandwidth,
or desire to reduce the
cost incurred on network
provisioning, or do not have the
network connectivity available
in remote and mobile scenarios.
Next, let's look at
the user experience
for transferring your
data with the TA300.
Customers start by submitting an
order form in the Google Cloud
console.
We validate your source
location needs and ship out
the appropriate appliance
for your requirements.
When you receive the
appliance, inspect it
for any signs of
damage or tampering.
A simple attestation
program is used
to validate that
none of the hardware
or software within the appliance
was tampered in transit.
Now, the appliance is
ready for you to use.
Simply connect it
to your network,
mount the NFS share
exposed, and copy your data.
Once all this
copying is completed,
you can seal the appliance.
This finalization step protects
the appliance and your data
from tampering during
transit, and it
is required before shipping
back your appliance.
When returned to our
processing facility,
we attest the integrity
of the appliance
and move your data securely
into the destination bucket.
We then inform you of
the successful completion
of the transfer.
As simple as that.
Next, let let's see the
individual capabilities
in detail.
The appliance is ready
to use when it applies.
You remove it from
the case, place it
on a desk or a rack shelf,
and connect the power.
All the cables you need
are included in the case.
The server itself is
designed for performance
and reliability.
All SSD drives give
you faster rates.
Networking can
scale up to 40 GBps.
And data integrity is maintained
across all the system layers.
This is a cost-effective service
with a simple usage fee model.
You can scale up the
capacity of transfers
by ordering multiple
appliances in parallel.
This can help you maximize
the usage of your source data
systems, the internet
speed, as well as optimize
the end-to-end transfer time.
Next, let's see how easy it is
to move your data to the cloud
with the appliance.
You do not need any
proprietary software
to move data into the server.
Just mount the NFS share
from your workstation and use
any copy tools--
like robocopy, rsync--
to move your files.
A single NFS share is exposed
with the entire capacity,
making it easy for
you to run many copy
processes in parallel.
The local command line interface
lets you initialize the server,
configure IP ports, and check
the status of the appliance.
The data on the server
is always encrypted
and we help you all along the
way with shipping, logistics,
and any required support.
We are looking to make the
new TA300 available in all
our main regions,
starting with the US,
then EU, and followed by
APAC in coming quarters.
Next, let's tour the security
features built into the TA300.
Customers care deeply about
the security of their data,
and we take this shared
responsibility seriously.
Starting with tamper-evident
tags on the Transfer Appliance
case to the TPM chip used
to validate the internals,
every step has been designed
and tested for security.
The remote attestation process
validates several aspects
of the appliance after
it has been in transit.
First, the TPM
module is validated.
Then, the platform
configuration registers
are used to check the immutable
root file system and software
components, such as
the bootloader, OS,
Google binaries, and
customer-managed public key
materials.
This is done both at the
customer site when they receive
the appliance and at Google
processing centers when
the appliance is audited.
Our processes are
built for supporting
all the key compliance
standards and audited regularly.
We are there to support you
in all the steps, including
wiping the appliance
and issuing a NIST 8088
certificate for that operation.
We are looking forward
to serving your needs
with the new offer.
Next, some important additional
resources and information.
Thanks so much, Ash,
for the session today.
ASH AHLUWALIA: I wanted
to thank everyone
who joined our session today.
I hope you enjoyed
our discussion
on the use cases,
challenges, and solution
that Google offers to enable
you to move your data to cloud.
ABHISHEK LAL: And we
hope you will try out
all the exciting new
capabilities that we
have announced today.
Thank you so much, and
really appreciate your time.